this is a production of Cornell
University thank you very much
Don and Meena for the very nice
introduction and I'm a big story for my
rusty English but if you complain about
my English is that because I learned my
English here in Ithaca so that's why
because when I came here Nina
didn't say that but when I came here I
didn't know almost any English so I
learned something keep on studying keep
on talking and and then I you know I
practice it for a long time but now it's
it's a little bit you know rusty but
anyway I hope you will understand what
I'm saying
I asked me not to give a seminar to
telling about the borinage and urban
forest research in Italy especially the
research that my group is coming out and
but I would like to give you an overview
of the research funds all over Europe
and in Italy Nina has just introduced me
I teach her body cash on urban forestry
ornamental horticulture green areas
planting and management and then
methodologies and tools to mitigate
climate change effects in the urban
environment also being the Dean so it's
quite hard time for me to deal with all
these things I've been in the board of
directors may I say for several years
and these are my research interests but
you will see some example of our
research in the last year first part I
would like to give you an introduction
of the School of Agriculture of the
University of Florence this is the
building is a very old one it dates back
to the late seventeen hundreds and my
office is actually here and it's the
office of the Grand Duke of Tuscany so
it's a very nice office with a lot of
frescoes but its frescoes it means it's
very cold in winter and very hot in
summer maybe the Grand Duke had some
systems to you know to adjust the
temperature
but anyway it's very cold but it's
located in the main park of Florence
about 80 hectares
so it's about 168 acres maybe 200 acres
something like that
full of very old trees pine trees oak mt
dia Planetree and so on and I'm coming
to the Dean of the school the school the
cultural diversity of Florence is formed
by two main department my department
department of agriculture and
environmental sciences and then the
Department of Agriculture Food and
forestry systems my department is mainly
focused on you know agriculture
chemistry I mean plant physiology and
and so on and the other one is mainly
related to forestry and then we have a
third sorry the third department which
is the Department of Chemistry we have a
lot of chemistry teachers in our school
so we we take direct them that them
directly from the Dartmouth chemistry at
present we are 27 full professor 52
associate professor and 38 researcher
total of 117 faculty position in in the
school actually this is just the main
bill that we have several different
buildings one is much more more than
much we have seven bachelor degree
courses which for us is three years but
two years like like you're like yours
I'm cultural scientists forestry and
environmental sciences nursery crop
sciences Food Sciences and Technology
wide life sciences we have a lot of
wildlife in Italy then we have
viticulture and only is it very
important for our region you know we
produce probably the best wines and in
the world together with French people
but we don't like to see that just to
say that but anyway and then we have a
new class a new course from this year
about wood technology which is another
important topic for my country then we
have six master degree courses two years
science and agriculture technology
tropical rural development which is in
English it's dedicated to people who
come
Africa South America Southeast Asia
country which are you know known for a
very tropical subtropical or equatorial
climate then we in science in technology
forestry system food technology science
and management of white life
environmental resources and then a new
one starting this year biotechnology for
Environment Management and sustainable
agriculture which is mostly in English
meaning that we have a few classes in
each other which slides in English and
most of the classes are taught in
English now we had to PhD programs first
one I was him I mean world involved in
agriculture and environmental sciences
and the second sustainable management of
agriculture researchers forestry and
food we have two facilities two main
facilities one is located in the Chianti
area it's a very old you know
farm dated back to the 12th century it's
very nice it's located in one of the
most beautiful places of our region and
here we produce mainly wine and olive
oil some cereals and fruit trees but
mainly wine and olive oil
and it's very nice it's old it doesn't
look very modern but it's it has it also
a very high importance in terms of
history and now we have another
facilities up in the mountains for
forestry studies still very old dating
back to the 1700s and there we can host
up to I guess forty students at the same
time they can sleep there they can eat
air we have all the facilities and they
have lots of forests around to study
forestry and wood technology so the
second part is dedicated to an Italian
perspective on research I would I should
say actually European perspective and
research because
most of our research money now comes
from Europe from the European Union I
have chosen a cop down approach starting
from the highest level of funding to the
lowest level of funding doesn't mean in
terms of money there is a difference but
in terms of you know the overall
structure so most of the money the real
money now comes from the program horizon
2020 and only if you are familiar with
this program it's a program that it's
inside the EU framework and it's a
program from research and emulation it's
started in 2014 and it will finish in
2020 but the research will finish you
know all the calls will be until 2020
but research will finish in 2023 24 it
depends on which kind of probably apply
for for example this is an example of a
research project which was funded by
European Union it's about green
infrastructure and urban biodiversity
for sustainable development and green
economy it has just finished it was
inside the 7th Framework Programme so
before horizon 2020 by finished last
year we had this huge conference in
Oviatt about this topic I'm sorry and
you know all the city which were
involved in the race you can see the
point in all of Europe and to in and in
each other in Milan and body were
involved in this huge problem which
produced a lot of publication and the
book which is called the urban forest
then there is another problem life plus
program it's different it doesn't fund
research it does fund project for
example just to give you a short example
you wanna if I'm in Florence I want you
change the layout of the parking lot a
huge parking lot transforming it from
the old-fashioned parking lot with you
know impermeable payment I want to
transform in a very sustainable parking
lot so I can ask for money to the
European Union I have to present a
project but it doesn't fund research so
that the word research shouldn't be
mentioned in any part you can do
research but nobody should should know
but anyway it started in 2014
horizon 2020 for example we we applied
to life last September October sorry
this cold life climate change adaptation
and we submitted this project which is
the innovative technology platform to
improve management of green areas for
better climate adaptation and thanks God
three weeks ago we you got a note from
European unit that this project was
funded with 2 millions euro something
and I personally got two hundred twenty
thousand euro for three years which is a
huge amount of money compared to usual
there's a lot of work to do we have to
monitor plants and you know any kind of
stuff for three years but anyway it was
very good to get bad news
why is that until probably 10 years ago
it was very hard to have from European
Union project about abort catch an urban
forestry landscape planning and strong
funded by European Union but things
changed and now there the European Union
is very sensitive to fun also this kind
of research they have this green
infrastructure program and they also
have this nature based solution every
nature and series programs so you can
apply for two coats there are two costs
every year so one is in
February the other one is early
September or the end of September it
depends and you can apply with for these
two different codes and I mean the
percentage of projects funded is less
than 10% which is know very low but
there is a there are a lot of calls
along say seven years so to cause
failure on putting calls so you have to
apply apply apply apply them probably
you will get some funds a third system
to get some funds not for research but
for networking is the cost action its
European cooperation in science and
technology because this acronym and it's
for the one of the longest-running
framework supporting cooperation among
scientists and institution researchers
across Europe now also researchers from
outside of Europe can participate with
this kind of cooperation
it doesn't fund research it does fund
exchange between researchers and it does
found a scientific mission short term
scientific mission for young researchers
so it's very good for young people who
want to have their career in the iboga
cottage and urban forestry sector for
example this cost action the name the
title of the cost action was green
infrastructure approach linking
environmental with social aspects in
studying and managing urban forests you
see that all Europe who was involved
except for some countries but also some
part of Africa Tunisia and Algeria
guests remember maybe Algeria no sorry
Morocco Morocco and Algeria and then
also the United States and Canada
because also countries from outside of
Europe can participate as a partner in
this kind of action yes yes
that you mentioned its that also open to
North American as a partner you can't
get money but we can get money to invite
people from outside of Europe to join
the group so you can get funded research
money but you can get funds to come to
Europe to give seminars to exchange
opinion and so on in this cross-section
there were five working sorry four
working groups first one was
environmental services of green
infrastructure and urban forestry
implications of climate change the
second one was related to social
cultural services of green
infrastructure and urban forestry
third one governance and the fourth one
is Task Force on integration and
dissemination and then we have some
working groups these are not funded it's
just a system to networking with people
all over the world and it's very
interesting the Food and Agriculture
Organization now has a strong interest
for the urban forestry last year they
developed that poster of flyers in I
don't know how many languages in all
over the world so you can download the
poster on your left from the FAO website
and they also produce the guidelines on
urban and peri-urban forests even though
FAO is mainly dedicated to you know food
and agriculture now they had a special
section on urban and peri-urban forests
there is a working group a part of this
working group we meet at least twice a
year
all over Europe last meeting was in
Portugal the next one will be Rome at
the end of April I will remember and
they have also a link you can be part a
member of this group so you can get
email you can get link update about
Congress conference all over the world
and you can refer to those two persons
who belong to
the FAO in-room they're both I tell em
but they speak a very good English much
better than me also because they they
are have half English both so their
parents are party telling start I think
English not America
I'm sorry okay I did it and now we have
a national level I don't know if you are
familiar with this project in Milan it's
the vertical wood
it became probably the most known
landscape project all over the world now
they're building skyscraper with
vertical woods all over the world
Germany France the Netherlands China
South America and and so on
so it it's called vertical wood it's not
a wood anymore sorry it's not anyway but
they they grow three up to the 30th
story in this and this building which is
very nice to see I don't know how how
much is sustainable but it's very nice
you can you can trust me and so at the
national level three years ago we got
some funds from the state for this
problem Tree City for three city
international project for a better
quality of life in our cities it
involved cities from universities from
all over Italy from Sicily from Rome
from Tuscany from the northeast part of
Italy from Milan so and it's finished
last year another project funded by the
Minister of Agriculture and forests of
by the Minister of University it's about
the role of urban greening on air
pollution mitigation just finished all
this and then another project we have
finished two years ago was this one we
developed a software for evaluating the
effects of species selection and
planning on microclimate unfortunately
the software is ready it's working
but the ministry hasn't released the
permission to you know put it on the
market so we are still waiting for for
that and the third part is research of
my group so going down down down we were
finally arrived at my department I know
the building is very ugly you know it's
its enemy don't know where actually this
picture was I think 15 years know maybe
13 years ago so these trees are much
bigger now they're turkey oak quite a
serious yes service the building is ugly
but it's very close to Florence you know
Florence I'm Florentin so I'm not the
right person to say something about my
city but I know that my city is one of
the you know target for tourists every
time I go in Florence Monday morning at
7:00 she's the afternoon Wednesday
morning lunch time always full of
tourists you cannot even walk sometimes
along the streets of Florence
but anyway coming back to research we
have some research projects I will show
you something we have international
connection that's why I'm here
and we have some university courses we
are managing plant nursery science
environment and green areas management
and then we have landscape architecture
together with the architecture
department and then I am um I should
manage this research lab or plant
nursery science environment and green
areas management I should because being
the Dean is quite hard for me to do
everything sort of had a person who is
actually managing this research lab we
have basic research for example we have
studying response mechanism to multiple
environmental stressors in matron and
woody species and we had just looking at
the effects on secondary metabolism we
are working on the evaluation
morphological physiologic and
biochemical properties and parameters
related to drought tolerance which
a big issue in in the Mediterranean
Basin you know and it's becoming bigger
and bigger configured either by you
because of climate change and now we're
working on urban trees and volatile
organic compounds addition of some
species typical of the our urban
environment and now we have applied
research more basics field research
field research I will refer merely to to
these research we have we are doing now
tuning up automated trees we have done
we have finished the root pruning
project to simulate Street works we are
working the project will we finish in
2021 about the effects of different
paving materials on growth performance
and physiology of two widely grown
species in in Europe and in Italy and
then we are studied evaluation of the
ability of some shrub species to
mitigate the effect the effect of
pollution in the urban and peri-urban
environment our philosophy is simple
research but very deep investigation so
we start from the field from
morphological characters physiological
characters per a meetings and then we're
going we go to the lab and we we have
all the analysis possible in our in our
lab and in other labs which are
connected to my lab first research
project we tried to simulate the effect
of Street works on two different species
which are known to be different in terms
of reaction to this kind of stress so we
cut the roots on one side both sides and
no current to compare the effects of
this stress on on tree on tree
physiology and tree tree growth
especially we wanted to calculate also
the consequences of roots events
on both theoretical meaning calculated
and measured by pulling tests resistant
to uprooting we did this research on
horse chestnut and on linden European
limitary we had 48 plants for each
species which were planned in 2004 and
we allow them to grow undisturbed force
for five years and then in 2009 we cut
the roots on one side both sides and no
cutting so these these were the three
phases control trenching on one side of
tree mild draweth or miles or my stress
and trench them on both sides of the
trees so we excavate a trench which was
70 centimeter deep at about 50
centimeter so two inch to two feet and
1.5 feet large and we measure shoot
growth stand by emitted growth and tree
- cannabis sites for 3 years we also
measure the physiology leaf gas exchange
maximal quantum yield of photosystem 2
for the chemistry and then we measure
pre-dawn water potential for 3 years
between 3 and 5 a.m. so very early in
the morning night in in the wood the
results results show that even after
four years as you can see here trees
hadn't recovered from the stress control
had much higher growth compared to the
single trench excavation and you know
double trench trenches excavation and
there was also a fictive species Celia
as expected to be was less sensitive
compared to horse chestnut which is
known to be very sensitive to this kind
of stress
you see here they should growth even
after three years is in histogram you
see difference in terms of shoot growth
and in horse-chestnut that was also
different between the two kind of
excavation so what was the take a
message from this research from a
physiological point of view has is
written there root severance on young
trees induce similar effects as a mild
water stress characterized by diffusive
limitation to photosynthesis recovery is
quite slow for years at least four years
from from the from the cutting and
Linden was harder than hosted
horse-chestnut was more resistant more
tolerant sorry more tolerant to this
stress compared to horse chestnut as
expected as it was expected to be the
other question was with severe trees
stand up we have a problem strong wind
in the last year in anything we had some
tornadoes which was a word which was
associated to United States or to other
part of the world now we have tomatoes
also in Italy so we wanted we wanted to
know if this kind of stress could affect
the tree resistant to uprooting and so
we pulled the trees after right after
the stress and then we pulled the trees
four years later and you can see that
even four years eight later there were
differences between the trees which
undergone the which were which were cut
which which fruit story were cut and the
control trees both in Linden and in
horse chestnut so after four years trees
had not recovered from the stress so the
conclusions that this kind of cut induce
a chronic mind water stress recovery is
and would damaged may be a pretty spos'n
factor for trees to be attacked by other
parasites being both animals like
insects and fungi and bacteria and then
the uprooting resistant was reduced by
excavation as it was expected but what
we did not expect is that the this that
blue stress was prolonged for at least
five years four years this year almost
ten years then growing season from from
the cut we will measure again we up to
the resistant of the trees by pulling
tests the limitation of this study is
mainly due to the fact that trees were
white quite you are young so they can
react much faster than probably no tree
like this plane tree in in Milan so
we'll see when the tree will be older we
will repeat again the root cutting
second experiment I would like to refer
to is about the FL different pavements
and growth and physiology of to shade
trees a European hackberry and fraxinus
or nose which is Finnish meter in
English here's a ten year study
evaluating the effects of soy sitting on
newly planted trees so we had four
different phases twenty four plots about
50 square meters in in surface we plant
we realize the the research field in
November 2011 and we planted the trees
in spring 2012 we had four different
paving material actually three
impervious design asphalt on the
concrete subgrade parable design curb on
a crushed rock subgrade and then pours
design epoxy resin plus even graded in
head on a crush drop subgrade and then a
control low soil covering at all -
speech
European hat berry and mana ash European
Ami train - 24 plants the species you
see when we planted the trees since 2012
we measure soil moisture soil
temperature soil oxygen content content
soil co2 efflux we measure should growth
DBH leaf gas exchange chlorophyll
fluorescence and then freedom and midday
water potential we also measure all the
meteorological variables like
temperature humidity and so on because
probably they are affected by the
different kind of treatments we left
some you know holes in the ground to put
our sensors for soy humidity soil
respiration and strong results after
this is our you know not the final
results because the as I said this
research will go on until 2021 soil
temperature was always high in the
parable treatment as you can see here
the the gray the gray bar is the
impermeable treatment the temperature
was always higher even in winter time
see even in winter time the temperature
of the the soil was higher underneath
the impermeable layer you can see here
maybe this picture is much better than
any kind of data any kind of tables of
histogram you see during this no fault
the be the plot with asphalt with a
warmer so the the snow at the very
beginning didn't stuck on this on this
plot while was very mean the control was
the belay was already a couple of
centimeters
once activated so take-home message
[Music]
these are the difference among payment
types with low trees meaning in the
middle of the ADI of the plots where the
root system probably
hasn't arrived yet so the impervious
payment infiltration is very low the
evaporation is very low the water
content is slightly below fill capacity
and what a candidate 45 centimeter depth
is slightly above fill capacity terrible
or loosing control you see that control
the infiltration is high evaporation is
high water content 20 centimeters 40% of
the available water and at 45
centimeters at or slightly below field
capacity I have to say that in these
three years of measurement the rainfall
was quite heavy we had a lot of rain in
the first three years complain so
conclusion SOI ceiling induce a three
point three to five warming in a salt 5
degrees Celsius warming the soil and
this effect is likely due to the
impaired evaporation and can mitigate it
using porous or terrible pavements we
had soil moisture increasing and with
soil ceiling and we found that the the
water in the soil was a bowl filled
capacity so it's not planted with trees
in the middle of the of the plots co2
accumulates below imperial payments this
can be a problem and also we found that
oxygen slightly declines below
imperative payments but with this was
quite obvious about the effort on trees
we found that especially South East was
not affected by different kind of
payment white fraxinus showed some kind
of my stress especially with the two
kind of payment in Paris and bamboo
white porous was pretty similar to to
control and
should both very similar these sill tees
and this is fraxinus okay the conclusion
that the planting trees in pave soils is
essential for us to maintain
evapotranspiration urban areas because
we needed to cool the atmosphere
payments at least in this case and
limited effects on growth and physiology
of newly planted trees but I'm referring
to the first three years where now you
know a piece ahead and we are going to
show probably new results in in a Hughes
cell T's is much more tolerant compared
to ash to manage this kind of stress and
also we have limitation trees are very
young so we don't know what will happen
in the long term with the impermeable
payments but anyway this research thanks
to the tree fund will go on until 2020
21 so further result would be much
different we have published a research
in environmentally their paper in
environmental research about the first
full year study and I was surprised to
see that some kind of pretty similar
study was published recently in the
international journal bio metrology but
they just measured the leaf benefice
instead of measuring all these
parameters we have measured so I'm just
surprised to have to see this paper
published with just one parameter visual
parameter and it's it's impacted you
know it's 2.2 m per factor so I have to
thank the tree fund because they give us
hundred thousand dollars to do this
research we started in 2012 as I said
the the plot was established thanks to
the local government but then we got
these funds to go on with research until
2021 and we'll check all these kind of
parameters to see we will
to use ground-penetrating rather
geologic synthesis make waves as bait to
check how the root system is distributed
underneath the pavement a third and last
we started last year topping is on
fashion in Italy I fight every single
day again stopping but my fight is
useless I am NOT succeeding it in
anything anyway this is not topping this
butchering it's not talking you see but
anyway are you distinguishing yes yes
plotting is something that you know it's
good if it's well done stopping it's
always bad and this kind of work is very
common in Italy unfortunately and
something's very sometimes very bad why
people talk trees I don't know I don't
know because I don't know I always try
to explain that chopping is dangerous
it's useless is much more expensive that
you have regulatory it arm tree its arms
trees and so on no no success they keep
on chopping keep on shopping sometimes
because they don't want to have leaves
in the full but I say you still have
leaves even if you talk trees maybe you
have more leaves in if you what we will
know about pruning and what what don't
we know
we have a lot of information taking
information but it seems to be a battle
against windmills you see it is like you
know Sancho Panza in Spain because even
though we have a lot of information
people keep on telling keep on asking to
musicality to top trees so I have the
idea why don't we try to show the effect
of chopping trees of microclimate
condition and show the people
how the microclimate condition can be
changed if you chop trees so we we chop
trees last year in February and we have
you know all these plots normal pruning
chopping normal putting and so on on two
species Lindemann Mountain maple a
subsea bloodiness and just the first
year we showed we saw some difference
you see the the orange bar are the
topped plot but and the the green bar
are the unpooled pods you see that the
temperature was always hired three to
five centigrade higher in the topped
plots compared to the UM Crone plus
three three years Detroit three degree
centigrade on average but in some days
the difference was nine eight to nine
degrees okay this is the same okay we
have a lone plots just beside the the
experimental plots so we also measure
the temperature and the humidity and so
on also in that body you see that there
was no difference between topped and
long and also phenology was affected
trees lost their lives before when they
were top compared to the unproven about
trees and then we have I'm going to
finish recent lines of research we are
studying the response mechanism of tree
species of oak to draw to it stress
according to climate change
and then as I said before is not there
now we are studying the secondary
metabolism in may trade and evergreen
species with height tolerant to osmotic
stress to explore the role of these
species as a bio factories because when
they are stressed they produce a lot of
antioxidants which
are good also for our health so in using
my stress on these species can be very
good to extract this compounds from from
from these species and to use these
compounds in the oncology and in the
pharmacology we're still doing research
about the air pollution abatement by
roadside vegetation barrier working on
shrubs evergreen shrubs we are studying
the isoprenoids and Fannie propanol in
their role in the draw stressed
resistance in London plain tree and in
European Hut berry and this is the last
research we're trying to understand
which are the mechanist in red and green
leaf tree species because it seems that
having red species means also to have
much more antioxidant oxidants in em and
in the leaves so it seems that red leaf
species can tolerate drought and life
stress much more than green leaves
issues it's just an ipod this is we are
starting it seems that our hypothesis is
true and we will work on no no we German
no we may pull sorry no a maple red
Norway maple Deborah which is half red
half green and then I think it's summer
shade just green we have published more
than 50 papers in impacted journals out
of this and previous Regis research
project and just to finish some
information if you are interested in AB
or occasion urban forestry there will be
the World Forum of urban forestry in
Mantua which is in the north of Italy
late November 20th on November 1st of
December Montreux is a very nice City
and the middle of flat land part of
Italy is very story they have a nice
lake just
close to the city the the conference the
Congress is the forum of sorry it's
organized by the FAO together with
international facial landscape
architects the Politecnico on Milan I
mean the scientific board and there is a
call for abstract which will the
deadline is 30th of April if I went man
so these are all the objectives of the
world forum of urban forestry so any
kind of research about Boracay and urban
forestry is welcome to this forum is the
venue and is the website if you are
interested in enjoying the the forum at
late November early December and just to
finish last year we publish this broad
rich handbook of urban forestry actually
Nena has two chapters right and in the
book and it probably covers all the
topics in the urban forestry and all any
single chapter is is written by the most
prominent researchers all over the world
so you can find anything everything in
this handbook it's a bit expensive but I
think there is you know it's it works
the money it costs okay that's all folks
if you have some question I'll be happy
to answer
you may question problem from Geneva I
forget to I forgot to say hello to
people from Geneva
once one small question thank you so
much by the way is your presentation
available online or by email
I will leave my presentation so I think
it would be online soon okay thank you
so much if you if you need more details
on the research because you know time is
sometimes it's short and I gave a
presentation last year was six hours of
all the research so I just do some
slides to give an example but anyway if
you want to know more you can write to
me my address email address I would be
very happy to share information research
and papers with you welcome don't be shy
native soil was a looming sandy loam
soil so it's local soil with some
skeleton inside so what's the normal
soil with a high pH actually was seven
point eight something it's the level for
Street payment so we followed the load
was one point six maybe more it sits in
the midst of people always everywhere
anywhere anytime I this morning I fought
with my mayor I don't live in Florence I
live just outside of Florence and my
mayor I know him very well he can call
me anytime
but last week they chopped some trees
and I got very angry very angry so
if you go to I have a Facebook page
which which is called amore cache an
urban forestry by Francesca furring you
can find you know picture you can
believe them
you really can't believe in how people
you know Mucha trees because there is
the difference between pruning and
cutting I can cut the tree
I cannot prune a tree because you know I
need some skills to and also some
knowledge to prune the trees cutting and
pruning are two different things
one more question but anyway if you have
questions just write to me I'll be very
happy to answer writing is much easier
than talking for me so ok yes we one of
my target as a Dean when I was elected
there was a strong competition just me
so I won and they told me they asked me
would you would you like to be the Dean
of this fool say wow if there is any
other person who want to be I mean at
the public seven is my duty to be the
Dean and I was in California got the
news I was elected so but anyway one of
the target I put on my list was to have
to establish closer connection with
University all over the world this means
a lot of trouble anywhere in the world
United States and nicest country but I
had traveled to Iran to Afghanistan to
Azerbaijan to Jordan to Korea and so on
so anywhere in the world to establish
closer connection to exchange students
and also researchers and professors so
if you have an agreement it's much
easier for some of us to come here and
for some of you also be students to come
truly to spend a certain period of times
doing research or attending classes or
whatever you want to do in Italy and
Johnny life may be on Saturdays and
sunny not only
weakness so yes so we have to have a
formal agreement and also we were
talking about to have a double degree
which will not be very easy I mean we
can do it but it it takes time I have a
double degree so students from Landscape
Architecture from Horticulture
Department can span here two years maybe
six months in Italy taking classes and
taking also exams and also the vice
versa so students from Italy can come
here and and the the main problem is the
different taxation system if the two
universities agree to not to put any
more taxes on these students it's quite
easy but for us the taxes is very low so
it's the opposite which is if you we can
adjust something so for example
landscape architecture students can come
to Italy to spend six six months or
maybe a year if they're interested
specially in historical landscape
management and storm our course is
specialised in historical management
historical landscape management which is
quite obvious in Italy let me thank you
very much for coming here I appreciate
it this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu